justamente empiezo preguntándole si esta
mayoría en el parlamento significa de
alguna manera que erdogan tiene un apoyo
mayor para ganar en segunda vuelta
Sí este apoyo que tiene ahora erdogan lo
que le posibilita es tener mayor
ampliación o mayor poder a la hora de
manejarse dentro de la asamblea aún así
parece ser que esta segunda ronda le
sienta bien a erdoan en el caso de
querer legitimar su sistema electoral
para que parezca que es un poco más
democrático y quizás se le pone un poco
más cuesta arriba al candidato opositor
que además es un candidato que está
formado por una coalición de partidos
bastante variopintos Aunque en su
mayoría se supone son socialdemócratas
pero acá se ve digamos fuertemente de
que para temas de la asamblea nacional
turca a erdoan se le abren las
posibilidades de poder ampliar su
gobierno cinco años más bueno el
nacionalista o han el candidato que
obtuvo el tercer puesto en apoyo aún no
se ha pronunciado qué tanto podría
influir en su apoyo en este balotaje
sí Este es un peso bastante importante
incluso están quienes hablan de
queerdoán tiene apoyo de gente cercano
al partido del akp verdad para el tema
de la asamblea nacional pero no así para
la presidencia en los próximos días
quizás podamos ver un poco más claro el
panorama quizás la parte más difícil es
que a nivel mediático el gobierno de
propiamente controla todo lo que es la
la prensa a nivel internacional lo que
es oficial y de hecho los opositores han
tenido que manejarse por rutas alternas
entonces de acá hasta el 28 de mayo es
el balotaje posiblemente
se tenga que empezar a dilucidar a
través de canales alternos Cuál es en
realidad la posición en la que está el
candidato opositor para poder lograr
ganar el balotaje el próximo 28 de mayo
qué significaría para la oposición ganar
la presidencia con la actual
configuración del parlamento
sería un camino bastante complicado
verdad con un control todavía de la
acapé bastante significativo pero por el
otro lado también es un cambio en cuanto
a la forma de gobierno del país que ya
no ha conocido digamos en los últimos 20
años otro líder que no sea erdogan en
este caso y que no sea el la forma en la
cual el akp ha querido controlar todos
los esquemas del Estado un cambio en
estos momentos podría significar
paulatinamente una reforma al sistema
Estatal Pero sería un poco arriesgado en
estos momentos Pues pronosticar digamos
grandes cambios debido a que la la
diferencia que se marca de la kp en el
en el parlamento Turco es bastante
significativo hasta el momento Bueno y
qué impacto tendría por el contrario en
la sociedad una eventual nueva victoria
de erdogan
Sí desde el punto de vista social hay
muchos de las provincias que ya están
cansados de la figura de erdoan verdad
ha demostrado y demuestra una vez más su
carácter autoritario un carácter que sea
extendido ya durante 20 años incluso
llevando un cambio de sistema político y
convirtiéndose en la máxima figura
Incluso en momentos cruciales como el
supuesto intento de golpe de estado del
2016 y que quizás se vio minado un poco
con el pasado terremoto que ocurrió en
el país y que y que lo marcó bastante
Pero de alguna manera para las fuerzas
opositoras y principalmente Para algunas
minorías una extensión del poder de
erdoan podría significar cinco años más
de autoritarismo y de persecución
algunos grupos que suponen directamente
a esta forma neotomanista que que se
maneja el presidente erdoan